Good morning John. In 1911, in a very early science fiction novel, Hugo Gernsback became the first person to predict
personalized news, when he wrote,  "the morning newspapers were transmitted to the sleeping subscribers by wire at about 5:00 a.m.
The newspaper office, notified by each subscriber what kind of news is desirable, furnished only such news"
More than a hundred years later, that future is more than now. Our personalised news sources would more accurately be called
Information and entertainment feeds and they contain everything from pictures of your cousin's baby to the unfiltered thoughts of the President of the United States.
But in Gernsback future
it was you who decided what news you wanted to see  - and that idea on its own may be troubling.
But now who decides what ends up in your feed isn't you. It isn't even a person.
It's a computer program and increasingly a program that built itself in ways that no one fully
understands;  to satisfy not /your/ needs, but the needs of the /platform/.
These machines are given desired outcomes, but how they get there is up to them and their goals are tightly held industry secrets.
But here are two things that are very clear. One: the information in your feed
And how it is served to you, can have a lasting effect on who you are
And how you feel, and two: the business model of social media relies on selling that power for a profit.
Due to a failing in Facebook policy and enforcement
Cambridge Analytica was able to create psychological profiles of tens of millions of Facebook users. "We have somewhere close to four or five
thousand data points on every adult in the United States". And then they could create not just
advertisements, but news stories and even entire news outlets specifically to amplify and exploit the fears and anxieties of
voters. This was a violation of Facebook's rules, but not of any laws because in the U.S.
there are so few laws regulating these companies. In fact, Facebook doesn't want anyone else to have your data
Because your data is their most valuable asset
But as artificial intelligence gets better, even small amounts of data will likely be enough
smaller and smaller signals are becoming clearer and clearer. Machines are now able to tell with 91% accuracy what a man's sexual orientation is
from profile photos. If you're wondering why Facebook is worth half a trillion dollars
It's because of its ability to capture your attention and because of what it knows about you.
When fed enough data, machines can determine shocking detail with tiny amounts of input
And they will use what they know about you, your worldview, and even your emotional state to help others
manipulate you -  as long as those people have the money to spend. This is not a secret conspiracy,
it's their business model. Facebook isn't the product that's being sold - Facebook is free. You are not the customer,
you are the /product/. On the social internet, your attention
is their dollars. And for them that means that anything that gains attention is good and whether they decide to have any
regard for truth, for the stability of society, for the health of their users is at the moment
entirely up to them. And while some of us will dive into these issues to at least understand, most people
won't have the time to do that and ultimately we /need/ Facebook. It's socially expected,
it's necessary, and it's a useful platform.
We're trapped, so the only thing to do is remember and to help others learn if you don't control the feed,
the feed
Is controlling you.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
John, our new media literacy series on Crash Course with Jay Smooth is so good and
fascinating, and I want to tell anyone who goes to watch it that it's gonna change the way you see the world around you forever.
It might be a little less cut and dried, but it's gonna be a lot more accurate.